good to have you this event in
pennsylvania underscores
yet another uh reminder of how important
pennsylvania
and its its 20 electoral votes are um
and i'm just wondering i post the debate
and the dust up over
what joe biden was saying about
eventually phasing out
up to the oil industry i know he's put
it back to 2050
but between that and confusion on
fracking the president was pouncing on
the thing this guy wants to
kill those jobs in states like yours um
what do you think of this as an issue is
it resonating with pennsylvanians
well neil i think the record's pretty
clear i think
it's clear from what joe biden has said
over and over again and
what i know to be the truth which is he
doesn't support a ban on fracking
but what he wants to do is make sure
that we do it the the way that it should
be done like
it's done in pennsylvania where it's
done in compliance with
environmental regulations and rules so
you're not polluting people's water
their groundwater their drinking water
and polluting the environment but
i think that record is pretty clear i
know the president's been trying to
muddy the water
not to overuse the analogy but i think
it i think it's pretty clear to people
and i think at the same time there are a
lot of people in our state that know
that we've gotta
we've gotta confront the challenge of
climate change and deal with it
and i think that's uh that's what he
says senator when he says senator i want
to transition from the oil
industry and try to clarify that i said
i've always said i don't know what's
surprising people
um you obviously have a big energy
fracking state
um are they all on board with the notion
that we are going to transition away
from that if i'm a
young worker and i'm looking for a job
in that industry
and i i'm hearing a potential president
say
that it's going to start phasing out it
doesn't seem to be much of a future in
it so i might look elsewhere right i
think there's a future
because in in our state uh fracking
not only provides an opportunity for job
growth and continued stability in the
job market
and a lot of employment but it also
makes us less dependent on
uh middle east oil so it's it's been a
great benefit
both in an energy sense as well as the
job sense but joe biden's going to
going to work hard to protect the
environment and make sure that we still
have those
jobs that uh that come from gas
extraction
but neil i think the no i understand
that but do you think he also addressed
senator the notion of taking away
subsidies up for the industry i mean
to hear that in a state like yours or
support for an industry that's such a
big employer
i guess what i'm asking is is that going
to hurt him in pennsylvania are people
going to hear that and say
look i know he's you know low emission
energy and all that i know he is for
cleaner fuels and all that
i just didn't know you know how anti he
was
all the stuff that we're doing what do
you say to them
no look neil i think it's it's pretty
clear and most people in pennsylvania
are concerned about
two fundamental issues right the the
virus and jobs in
the economy both of which are
interrelated you can't
we can't recover fully until we tackle
the virus that's why
the difference between the candidates in
the presence so does that have a virus
plan
no plan to tackle the virus no plan to
create good paying jobs he's good
joe biden's going to be in luzerne
county today that county right now as of
the month of
uh just the last monthly number 18 000
people out of work 12 percent
unemployment
and and almost 28 000 people lose their
health care if they get their way on
destroying the affordable care act so
when when people in luzerne county or
northeastern pennsylvania are statewide
are thinking about the election
they're thinking about two things tackle
the virus and
and have a jobs plan joe biden's got
both
and i think that's why he's ahead all
right it might be and you're quite right
we haven't seen any polls post his
comments in the debate here but if
you're looking at lazarin county i guess
there's 12 percent unemployment rate you
allude to senator it could be a lot
worse
um if if the the energy industry in your
state
in that county is walloped right i mean
how does he address that what do you
think he does
but neil that unemployment rate in
luzerne county in pennsylvania and
america
could be a lot better if the president
got serious about tackling the virus i
i have one question for the president on
the virus you have to wonder
would donald trump have gotten the the
coronavirus
if president trump did a better job
tackling the virus
we've got us we need a strategy neil to
to put this virus behind us we should be
ahead on that
and we should be further down the road
of creating millions of good paying jobs
160 countries have it right i mean the
the president of poland was just
diagnosed tested positive of the virus
right now right
as was the leader the prime minister of
britain not too long ago so it's
right it seems to have certainly
reckless abandon when it comes to
picking and choosing where
it targets and who it targets is across
the globe so can you really blame the
president
um for that especially when we look at
death rates which is
tragically a metric you should consider
uh per 100 in the u.s is 11th is used
11th on that list i'm not minimizing the
debts i'm not minimizing
hospitalizations i'm not minimizing
everything that's happened
but on a per capita basis there are
countries on this planet
a halo of a lot of worse no but neil i
think here here are the important
numbers on death
deaths and cases four in 20 we've got
four percent of the world's population
we've got 19 or 20 percent of the deaths
that
that number has been pretty steady and a
little bit higher
20 or 21 percent of the cases in the
world
just on that alone it's clear that we
are not where we need to be
i look i live in northeastern
pennsylvania one county over from luzarn
county i'm in lackawanna
our case numbers are going up in in
these counties going up statewide
we have to tackle the virus and it would
be great for the country
if the president wore a mask all the
time i could give him one that says vote
on it
and and have it have a strategy talk
about tackling this virus every day
everyone would be better off he could
affect the behavior of tens of millions
of people
and we know if more people are wearing
masks more people are taking it
seriously
we can put the virus behind us and fully
recover
all right we'll see what happens senator
casey thank you for taking the time
uh beautiful state of pennsylvania